so when when people ask me what I do and
I say working fashion people often say
Oh with models and I often say yes but
of course I'm talking about statistical
models rather than the human variety so
who had anyone who does know who lists
are we basically sell clothes but the
difference for us is that we collect all
our information about clothes
dynamically from the web so if you think
of it in terms of data science our main
goal is to take this stream of
inconsistent semi-structured fashioned
data and transform it into a consistent
catalog for our users and then our users
can buy stuff from us so basically the
wait list makes money is by transforming
data into this consistent thing that we
can present so fashion it's an
interesting business to be working in
particularly because it's fashion
there's a visual medium so a lot of
things that users are interested in are
captured by text or descriptions or
products like I think you'd be very
hard-pressed to describe these products
and do them justice for instance you
really need the visuals to appreciate
the outfits fully so it makes sense for
us when we're doing things like search
or we're doing recommendations or were
doing duplicated product detection or
trends forecasting anything like that
we should have visual features in our
machine learning models okay so today
I'm going to talk about this can we
build a general-purpose fashion model
that we can feed into all of our data
science processes and machine learning
models at lists so the way that we can
achieve that is through deep learning
I'm not going to go into too much
details about deep learning in this
presentation but I want to talk about
two aspects that for me where all the
benefits come of using deep models so
compositions is there's like two things
to think about in terms of competition
compositions like that architecture that
you're specifying and there's like
parameters so I'll talk a little bit
about the parameters obviously one
reason we use deep learning is because
it's accurate and it gives us high good
performance and the reason for that is
the relationship between the degrees of
freedom of the decision boundary and a
deep model and a number of parameters is
exponential because we're stacking
parameters are above each other so one
set of parameters influences the next
that influences the next you get this
hierarchical effect of the parameters
whereas you think of a more classical
model like regression or a random forest
then there's almost a linear
relationship between the number of
parameters you have and you'll
discriminate discriminative power so
that's one thing about deep learning
that we get a lot of power from a
relatively small number of parameters
but the bit that I really like is this
architectural composition so all right
think of it with a traditional model if
you want to do something very bespoke in
particular to your problem you have to
be a carpenter you have to derive lots
of things from scratch do lots of
research with deep learning if you want
to do something very spoke and specific
to your problem it's a lot more like
Lego or IKEA for example you just take a
lot of components that exist in the
ecosystem and you can slot them together
to create something really bespoke for
your problem I'm gonna go into this a
bit later when I talk about our model
okay the other thing is representations
this is probably the most one of the
most powerful things about deep learning
although representations aren't
necessarily only for deeper and you can
have known these non deep
representations like word to vac is an
example that's a non deep representation
or even like classical image processing
has a lot of sort of key point
descriptors and various vectors that
could be considered representations as
well
but why representation is important well
I want to do this quote from Bango in
his 2004 paper so so a I must
fundamentally understand the world
around us and this can only be achieved
if it can learn to identify and
disentangle
underlying explanatory factors hidden in
the observed milieu of low-level sensory
data that's a very academic sentence but
I think it gets to
it gets to the heart of the matter
around representations so essentially
you know models need more than simple
point wise symbolic concepts so I'll
show you example they need like deep
context around the things they're
modeling so she a good example so here's
some concepts that I presume we're all
familiar with cats and dog which were
animals male female male which agendas
and I don't think anyone would argue if
I said you know cats are quite close to
dogs and females are quite close to
males if you think of the semantics of
those terms are very very close but so
this is the audience participation
section of the presentation so if we
take cats would you say cats is closer
to female or closer to male in terms of
in terms of the semantics what we just
say the concept of cat is closer to male
or female but okay who votes male okay
who votes female okay good good this you
haven't ruined the presentation
likewise dog closer to female closer to
male yeah good thank you good audience
so that is really interesting I think
because if you take this like
traditional view on AI say like the
symbolic approach where if we were
modeling text and we wanted to represent
a cat to our model we'd probably do
something like a one-hot encoding vector
which is a point wise estimate has no
context around it it's just a symbol
it's just a 1 like this is a cat and we
know nothing else about cats like clay
with dogs or females or males it'd all
be these point wise estimates point wise
encodings so why why do humans think the
cats are close to female and dogs are
close to male
you have like this rich context
surrounding these symbols like this rich
semantic context that underlies the
surface symbol and that's what we need
to put in the models as well the models
need to understand that cats and dogs
are similar with males and females are
similar and so forth and that's where
representations come in so instead of
just using like one hot encoded symbols
we use vectors which we call the
representation that vector somehow
encapsulate s-- knowledge about that
symbol that we're interested in so again
I'll show you some examples later ok so
the model so this is our data Atlas
typical data we have a product an acne
jacket and we have three different
images of that jacket from three
different retailers I'm not usually to
see like different lighting different
models different angle different
saturation all those things and we could
also have multiple images from one
retailer like typically would be the
rotation of the product right or
different angles of a shoe or something
like that so first thing about our
products we have multiple images the
second thing about our products is that
we have multiple labels so you can see
example here so we know that the
products for man we know it's color we
know and the jackets likely shiny it's
got zip and edited we know it's a jacket
so we have all these various labels that
we can attribute to our products so when
we train this visual model and get our
representation the model should be able
to take multiple images for each
observation and it should be able to
optimize that representation based on
multiple labels that way we're making
use of all our data and all our
knowledge about fashion so this is a
sorry you probably can't see this where
I've got zoomed in one coming up but
this is the rough architecture very
high-level architecture of the model
that we've designed I just quickly go
through a high level all we do is images
go in at the top the images go through a
bunch of convolutional layers and the
architecture we're using for convolution
is something called Zed
said f net is like a slightly better
version of architecture called Aleks net
and Aleks net is architecture that sort
of came onto the scene and blew
traditional image processing away and
won all the competitions this is a
slightly improved version but this is
and this is actually quite an old
architecture there are even new fancier
ones but the very computation expensive
you need multiple GPUs and the hard to
use on production and that sort of thing
so we're going with like a simple one
that just works so and this can also
easily run on multiple GPUs if you want
to speed up fitting we use something
called data parallelism where we take
our training batch split it into n
chunks for n GPUs give each GPU a chunk
and then do the forward pass and then
get the representation at the end and
consolidate it all so you can speed up
that way if you want by the way this is
all done in China which is a Python
library that basically has its own CUDA
bindings for the GPU and it's very easy
to use it's good at multiple GPUs and
it's error messages are really easy to
understand so then if anyone's got
experience with Fearne oh that's
probably the opposite in theory I know
but it's a bit slower than Theano so it
doesn't do graph optimization or
anything
okay so let's zoom in a bit so if you
remember R 2 R 2 R 2 things we wanted to
achieve is multiple images per input and
multiple labels how can we do that in a
deep network well the multiple labels is
actually incredibly easy to do in a
neural network all we do is how we
calculate multiple losses at the end of
the network so in a classical model your
loss might be you know mean squared
error or softmax cross entropy or
something like that where you're saying
how well is my model currently
predicting my labels and it gives you a
number in this case if we have five sets
of labels or ten sets of labels we just
have ten losses so we have ten different
numbers that say how well is the model
doing against our ten labels and to
consolidate that all and update
rameters we simply take the mean of all
the losses and backprop that so we're
just taking the mean of all the tasks
and putting that back through the
network you can't do it in fancier ways
so you can just sum them together and
weight them if you think one task is
more important than the other or
whatever you want to do but all the
tasks are important for our
representation so we're just taking the
mean the other bit which is slightly
trickier is how do we put multiple
images into our deep model and get a
single with get a single prediction for
them and a single representation so what
we actually do is when we're creating
batches for our model we group images
together so that every image in about
every product in a batch has the same
number of images so say we have a batch
of 2000 products for training on every
product in that batch we'll have say 5
images so they all have a consistent
amount of images then we take our
convolutional part of on your own
network and duplicate it five times one
for each image we put them through the
five copies of the network
simultaneously and at the end we'll have
five representations coming out for each
image to combine them we simply take
these five representations which are
vectors stack them into a matrix and do
column average pooling across all
columns and we get back to a vector but
the vector is now they see column wise
mean of every single image
representation you can also do max Max's
option as well and the idea is say are
the first column of our representation
represents I don't know how red a
product is I mean it wouldn't be this
obvious to say it does then if we use
something like max pooling we're saying
if any image contains something red our
final representation should say
something is red that would be max
because we're taking the highest
activation from the column whereas mean
is sort of average it takes the average
of all the activations it's a different
way to do it the reason we're doing
reason did averages that we found we've
got better results on color on the color
tasks
predicting the color of a product one
we're doing average pooling over max so
that's that and then if you so it's
actually quite easy to do these two
things it's not too tricky
we've just combined a bunch of
components stuck them all together and
now now we can do multi task and multi
image learning if you think how would
you do this with a random forest or a
sphere or logistic regression right it
would be much much harder I think to try
and do this so some details on training
we train for about 20 epochs on our GPU
it's about five hours at you park so -
and that's actually quite fast for some
of these models the more modern ones
literally take it days and there's about
60 million parameters so if you think
think of a regression problem we've got
60 million coefficients basically
impossible to look at them and try and
figure anything out and about on it
strain them about four million images so
we train that for a few days and then we
can test it out with something like this
so we put in a pair of blue this is a
very easy example it's very clean it's
very blue if there are more complicate
ones that don't work quite as well but
so we put these three images in got a
representation and run predictions on a
representation you see it it gets it
right yeah so blue is for men this issue
it's a sneaker it's a low top so that's
good
not always as good but it's good and
then overall we get about 80% accuracy
on all our images with the lowest actor
of being subcategory which is quite hard
to predict because it's it's things like
maxi dress versus cocktail dress versus
evening gown and all look they all look
the same to me so the fashion people
come up with them and also color and the
problem what the reason the color is so
low only 73 percent it's just because
color is really ambiguous even for
humans so you can see when our humans
make decisions when does beige become
white when does beige become brown when
does very pale green become grey when
does pale blue become great
and as all these decisions basic each of
our human moderators has a different way
of doing it so there's some
inconsistencies and sometimes products
are multiple colors like black and white
and they'll only be tagged with one
color and our model thinks it's white
but on moderator thinks it's black so I
mean it is right but not according to
our labels so we're gonna show you
something later it shows how these
inconsistencies arise so internal so
we've trained it let's have a little
look inside so here's a nice image so
what we did here is took maybe 50,000
products the model had never seen before
so it wasn't part of training calculate
representations for every model using
all the images again the representation
is just a big vector then we project
this vector down into two dimensions
using test knee and then plot those on a
plane so essentially things that are
near each other should be similar to
each other semantically and you can see
it works quite well with this little
island they're all handbags they've all
got a handle that's up so it looks like
if you think some of our tasks are about
shape and it seems like the
representation is understanding shape
its grouping things together you see in
the top corner as well there's a little
belt island so it seems to be grouping
shapes well that's good
one of our other tasks is color and it
seems to understand color as well as we
have sort of like a a rainbow of bags
going across so it seems to understand
how to group colors together as well so
this is like a nice debugging method
just to make sure you're doing not doing
anything crazy okay here's another one
so the nice thing about convolution
confidence the first layer of a conflict
is that images of three channels red
green blue so your filters your
basically what you're learning on the
first layer of the content also has
three channels so you can just take them
and plot them as images and it's a nice
way to quickly debug the first layer you
can't do that for other layers because
they have hundreds of channels and you
no idea how you could plot by an image
form right
so what you see here is 7x7 filters each
square is a seven by seven that's
running over our input images and trying
to and it will be activated when image
is similar to the filter CC say maybe
we've got like a blue filter if the
image is blue every time that filter
hits something blue it'll be a little
fiery signal will be like a house blue
and then we can take that as part of our
classification so basically here you see
there's color filters but sort of color
edged detecting filters in some cases
like this green this red and pink one
where it's detecting boundaries between
colors and then we have these sort of
black and white classic as detectors
that will be used for finding shape and
that sort of thing so it looks right
it's not noisy it's again it's another
debugging technique just to check that
nothing's going wrong okay let's go on
to a bit more of a complicated technique
that I I don't really have an
explanation for why it looks like it
does but so what do we do here like I
said we can't plot the inside of the
model past the first layer because it's
too high dimension and there's no way to
visualize it so what we do instead is we
take random images of Gaussian noise put
it into our network look at the
activation for the layer we're
interested in to say like the activation
is 6 then we optimize the image itself
instead of the network to maximize the
activation threshold so the other that
activation the idea is we're evolving
images that excite certain neurons
maximally so they should then somehow
reveal what that in your wrong is
looking for and what it's interested in
so on the left this is the second layer
and you see I don't if you can see other
well but it's basically like little
colored dots and patterns so it's trying
to detect which makes sense for that
layer because you don't you're not
necessarily looking to find structure at
that layer the idea is that each layer
your composed these filters to build
structure as you go higher and higher
and higher but then at the third layer
we have these very
are sort of like diffused colorful
clouds and why I don't really know I'm
not sure what you expect to start
finding structural outpoint like lines
and curves and things like that but we
don't have it so it's either then the
network strange because we're using
multiple images of multiple tasks so
maybe the filters come out differently
or all my script is just not working
which is probably the more likely
example but chooses something okay so
let's talk about color before here's
another nice one so here we've trained a
model only on color and we've done the
same things we did before so we project
it Institute the representation into two
dimensions and put the results and you
see that it's more or less clustering
colors together correctly it's that's
good there's a few interesting things on
here that highlight the problems we have
with labeling color so you see in the
middle it's just sort of like a big
weird blob of like brownie yellowy
greeny gray and if you look at this this
is actually confusion between a bunch of
color labels we have which is like khaki
beige white green yellow and the problem
is like the humans themselves have
different interpretations of what these
labels mean so our model is very
confused and doesn't really classify
them together for this if we wanted to
make this perfect I think I would Riaan
code all these sort of colors as natural
as natural which a lot of other
retailers do and so to get rid of this
confusion about car key in beige another
interesting thing is in this far side we
have like a red D orange e blob which is
weird because we've got a massive red
blob or the bottom is surely that red
should be with the main red if it's
truly red and if you look into this what
it's actually happening is these colors
are more like a Coralie that's pink and
orange coral I guess corals right yeah
thunders not things yes there's more
like a coral starts interesting we don't
have a coral label for colors but the
model is said although you're calling
these Reds
from what I've learned these are
different from the other Reds you're
telling me so it's a cool technique that
we've actually found new labels that we
should be using and there's also a
similar on in a different plot we've got
a similar one for teal because teal is
between green and blue
and we don't have a label for that says
some people say green some people say
blue and the models like what's
happening okay so that's koa okay
another cool thing we did with this
model to try and improve color detection
is what we said what about if we take
the first layer and we just do one by
one filters so there's no spatial
information at all it's basically just
learning a pixel value and the idea here
was Nate we thought maybe if we had 1x1
filters a limited number of them would
effectively be quantizing the image
colors before it goes into network you
know we're basically mapping it down to
a lower dimensional color palettes but
that color palette has been learned for
a particular data set so you thought
this would be cool and it does work
improves accuracy like by one or two
percent and these are the filters that
come out so it's quite cool I get I
haven't actually looked at later layers
with this model but the theory is that
perhaps these filters will then get
composed together to detect new colors
and they'll mix together to detect
colors we haven't seen yet and so forth
or multiple colors or multiple detectors
will all be used for green multiple for
red and that sort of thing and if you
look at it we've mostly got Reds you
know red green and blue and I guess a
little bit of yellow as well but that
works quite well okay so another
technique we can do is deep dream so are
you might have seen deep dream where we
it's basically the same as way that we
get the filters out the images we're
evolving images to maximize activations
but instead of putting random noise in
we put actual image in so this one's
trained on a model on color and it does
this so what's interesting about this is
it seems it does seem to be quantizing
the image in two distinct colors like it
you see it splits the sky up into blue
I think these weird green line things is
that the actual color that it thinks is
so if this was a dress the model think
it would be green I don't think okay we
can do the same with category so
category I think is shape so here we
have a white image and on the side we
have an image of a dress so if we do the
process in this only on shape we get
something like this so what's
interesting about this is like the noisy
image just sort of goes all blobby
the empty image goes all blobby the
dress image is just the same but the
shape of the dress stays can you see
that it's not being overwritten with
blobs like in the noisy image so I think
in some way that's showing it is
detecting the shape of a dress and the
model gets this right it says this a
dress so I presume it's something along
those lines don't know what the blobs
are to be honest it's work in progress
and here's another one this is color and
category if we put them together
oops sorry is it going okay so we put
them together it sort of turns into a
blobby gray shape and it gets color and
category correct so it is doing
something correct it's hard to interpret
bass like I don't know why it turns
everything into sort of like ovals like
the shoes and the legs and the arms but
it's interesting
okay so last one I just thought let's do
category let's do all our tasks on a
landscape and see what happens in C so
what happens here is you sort of get a
combination of color quantization and
edge detection all at once but again
it's very strange because I'll show you
the normal deep dream from a standard
object detection Network you get
something like this right
so it starts putting sort of dogs and
guinea pigs in eyes everywhere but that
but my model definitely does not do that
it's a sort of quantum it kind of makes
it this abstract painting so again this
is just interesting there's no
interpretation of what's happening
yeah and another nice thing we did and
my colleague Marsha did something
similar to this and we're trying to
transfer styles between dresses so we
take an empty dress and a dress with a
pattern we try and put the pattern on
the empty dress my office will be so
cool and all it managed to do was change
all the buttons to eyes so not that
useful really okay so final bit I've
shown you the model shown you inside
sorry I cut off for more interpretation
of what it's actually doing inside so
what can we do with this representation
so here's a product on list a 500-pound
sweater hoody standard and you see we
have images and we have very noisy text
and the designers write things like oh
this would be perfect on a sunny morning
walking down the lane with your friends
and they do all these white fluffy
descriptions it's not factual
so the descriptions are very very noisy
but they contain like nuggets of good
stuff we want right like they might say
it's made of leather dryclean only has
Raglan sleeves were like we need that's
amazing labeling that we'd like for our
models so question is how can we take
this description take the representation
of the image that we've just learned and
somehow extract the knowledge from our
description so we do something like this
so this is a model of two parts the
first part on the left is basically word
to vac we're just reimplemented words
avec so for each word in the description
we try and predict that words based on
the words that surround it and in this
way you build up a textual
representation and it understands things
like you know morphological and
invariant so like going and go are very
similar and it learns to say dress is
similar to skirt but it's not similar to
scar our hats and those sorts of things
so it's learning about the textual
context a context of each word and again
this is representation that we've been
talking about
then we mix that with another model
called a triplet network which Calvin
will be talking about more later and
what a triplet network does it takes a
representation take something you have
positive and a negative and it tries to
move it towards the positive and away
from the negative so we estimate our
representation from the text then we
take our image representation for the
two images and try and move the text
reputation representation closer to the
positive image representation and
further away from the negative yeah this
is actually a terrible example because
they're both coats so it doesn't really
there's a whole like asked around
sampling the correct negatives but here
it would move away from the pink coat
even though it is a coat so in this
manner and then again we have two losses
we mix them optimize a network so hope
so now we have a representation that has
jointly embedded images and text in the
same space so we can do distances
between images and text so let me show
you that what happens with the words of
Eck here's a few word pairs when I say
Lex called distance here I mean edit
distance how far away are the words in
terms of their characters and semantic
difference I mean the cosine distance in
the representation space we've just
learned so a couple of interesting
things flared and flare they're very
close in their word form they're very
close in their meaning that makes sense
opening and opening they're very close
in their spelling but they're actually
quite far apart in their meaning in our
data so I presume that's because they
use four different sorts of products so
maybe opening is used for trousers like
leg opening and maybe openings is used
to say button openings or something like
that so they're like although they look
the same they used in semantically
distinct ways and that's what learning
these representations gets us I mean the
most interesting when one is loops and
belt loops so they're very far apart in
terms of edit distance like live but
they're almost identical in the semantic
space so that's telling us that we never
use the word loops outside the context
of belt loops you've never used loops in
another context in our fashion data so
we you can start seeing we're getting
power about what words matter and what
how they're related so then if we take
our earth so then if we take a product
all the words in the description and
rank them relative to the image
representation in theory we should get
free keyword extraction and that's what
we get so here's a here's a shirt from
Ralph Lauren and we were also in playing
with Mike so we rank all the phrases so
we take diagrams and things like that
these are the most relevant for this
product so you get things like
embroidered logo button-down placket
point color classic slim fit these are
awesome labels that will make our models
even better when we retrain and they're
totally free like we haven't had to pay
anyone to get these labels we're using
the descriptions of products is weak
labeling and extracting the most
important ones from that weak labeling
so finally I just want to go back to
start the most important things for me
are composition and representation and
you can see here with both these models
we've just composed we've just like lego
together existing bits of functionality
to fit our domain and in the second
example we even took a whole model and
just put it into an another model so
that we can do keyword extraction so
it's all about this composition that
gives us a lot of power and lets us move
very quickly and the other thing is
representation none of the stuff I'm
doing here will be possible if we only
had a model that could do predictions
it's only possible because we have a
model that generates representations
okay so that's me
after straight after my colleague Calvin
will be speaking also I'm using this
representation for other exciting things
and he's also going to talk about his
sort of journey into deep learning and
all the pitfalls and that sort of thing
Thanks
Thanks great talk I have a question how
do you make your initial corpus two to
use for labeling the data all right so
we have humans who labels stuff for us
and basically we have like this
consensus process where we give them
image weight and multiple people will
select labels and we wait till they
converge and we sort of give each I
don't want to stop calling them humans
it seems like very like dehumanizing
yeah
no no they're real people that we know
yeah and then so we sort of rank them
and we know which ones are good and
which ones are bad and have this
consensus process but they're still like
definitely error rates around this
labeling but it's quite expensive
process we're lucky we have it but it's
hard to do from you you oh yeah sorry so
you said how large does the corpus need
to be to be effective the training data
well of course with neural networks the
bigger the better
so we actually have about sixty million
images but I only use four million for
this just cuz it's painted download them
basically even from our own servers but
a Calvin's work and getting more images
for us so basically the more you get the
better if you've got 10,000 images then
basically the model has so many
parameters it's just gonna over fit
immediately it's just gonna you put
10,000 images it's gonna you know like
the decision boundaries just kind of
like and just perfectly outline the data
and overfit so you do need a lot of data
because the data provides the
regularization to make the problem hard
if you don't have that variance and
input is the problems too easy for the
model and you won't get a good thing out
so more than more the merrier
so you have multiple objectives in your
first network that you present it have
multiple objectives that you train at
once by averaging have you tried
revolving literature sometimes they
either peak
the most informative objective and drain
it first and then they alternate the
objective something else or they
alternate throughout the process they
sample at the final layer and say okay
I'm gonna drain this now randomly yeah
have you played around with these like
no I haven't played a sorry did you
didn't hear that I'll repeat it so he
basically said we're averaging the
losses in a multi task network but could
you either randomly pick one task at a
time to back prop all with so what
people people usually do is that you
pick the most informative um jack
objective for example in the
classification of like a jacket probably
a jacket is more informative in tech in
terms of structure in the image rather
than color so you would like to pick up
the structure first and then continue
with your training the later a box we
say color for example or additional
things that might be more detailed right
I see so he said so the we did averaging
just because it's basically the simplest
approach to start with but yeah there's
loads of quotes so we can do things like
drop tasks as well once a and once
they've trained up and give more power
to the other tasks I mean yeah there's
lots of things we can do but we haven't
we haven't plays with any of it yet have
a go hello I'm sorry can you talk a
little bit about why you felt you needed
multiple images that's the one bit of
the story that I found a little bit
strange is it feels like you disrupt
information by having multiple copies or
multiple different images and then
averaging them yes so I mean there's two
reasons that one is it sort of well
primarily because we want
representations on a product level for a
lot of our machine learning structure
right so if we're doing something like
recommendations we don't want to
recommend people images we want to
recommend them products don't they get
tied together by having common labels
though and what you mean the images tie
together the products yeah but I mean
for instance with are all duplicates we
did it on an image basis and you do and
you run into we have like run into
problems before by having an image based
representation instead of having a
product-level but I've tested it without
multiple images and you actually get a
lower accuracy over it's only little I
mean probably if you did it on an
image-based level you wouldn't lose that
much to be honest but it's like one or
two percent accuracy and it just makes
deployment and integration into our
machine learning out it's easy basically
but I think you could do on images yeah
sorry that's do you think your model
recognizes the presence of a human model
if yes was it trained to do so and if
yes is it useful to then discriminate
other characteristics does it detect it
as a model in the image yeah I mean was
it trained to do so because in principle
that's one thing you don't want to
average across images some may have some
not well we one of our one of our tasks
is also gender so in a way having the
models face it's quite useful if we want
to distinguish between the gender and
you said you saw in the example it
actually takes when we're just dealing
with category yeah actually actually
just fades the model out of faith the
model Allen doesn't care about the model
just leaves the shape of the dress so I
think the important thing with these
deep methods is you yeah you don't want
to do pre-processing you just want to
provide enough data and enough
classification power for the model to
learn whatever it needs to learn and you
don't want to enforce priors on it
essentially if that makes sense
hey again about multiple images yeah
when you say to you you averaged the
vector representation and you said we
gave an example where a simple example
where one component might be learning
something's red or something like that
how do you kind of ensure that they line
up between the independent networks or
does that kind of automatically happen
or drop out no no that's a good question
so when we duplicate the network and
times we're not we don't have new
networks or new parameters we are
exactly the same network it's basically
the same as doing effectively through
the network five times basically yeah
it's a very exact ly same cool how do
you validate the output that you are
getting is there hue
intervention so you're scraping your
information from various website then
you are running through your machine
learning process is there then a
validation to a human yes sorry I
haven't been repeating questions but
he's asking how do we validate our data
that we're scraping essentially so at
the moment all us great data goes
through humans and we trying to develop
models in order to like aids those
humans and replace bits of them like
bits of their job not bits of dozen that
there is but so it's like it's basically
like human-in-the-loop style right we
have this train have this collaborative
ecosystem of man and machine and we try
and take the best from both and combine
them but there's yeah we have tough
validation the spiders actually returned
some so the machine is a helper don't
pan sorry the machine is helping exactly
that's the idea yeah I think you
mentioned it but I'm not quite sure of
Anasuya correctly you said before that
you use four million images to train the
model to Train it on yeah you have to
manually a handle a million or how do
you how do you deal with that massive
amount of images that you want to label
before you train the model well we're
lucky because I mean we be going for
five six six years and since the
beginning we've always had moderators
labeling our products for the site
because there's our retailers our
partners give us very inconsistent
labels one might call it blue one might
call it cerulean hyper wave right they
use all this weird language so since the
beginning we've had in-house moderators
who are labeling for us so we have 60
million labeled images now so it's a
nice resource to have as a data
scientist yeah so didn't cost us now
and thank you for the prototype and you
mentioned about lot of problems related
to the trick labeling of colors hmm
do you really need colors of as levels
instead of just using color colors
arpund in a continuous space so country
uses just vectors for them or
presentation oh sorry sorry what will
only be possible to just trying trying
to get a main color which is a vector
and not a color label instead of the
product okay right yeah I've got another
presentation on color and we did play
about that's why I like instead of
getting labels why don't we just get RGB
these right rank or something along
those lines or lab values and we have we
did actually try that out but there's a
few problem like say for example uses
one color labels cuz that's like the
fashion norm when you're on a high-end
fashion site it's always color name
filter so if we showed them like a
Photoshop style like color spectrum that
might be a bit confusing and the other
thing is like even if you have color
values it's really hard to map those two
names because there's nothing in the
spectrum of light that suggests it
should be segmented into labels right
it's just as a continuum so the labeling
of these intervals is entirely human
thing and it's actually quite hard for a
computer to understand why this is gray
and why this is beige it's like there's
no just see what I mean so like the
relationship between the colors and the
labels is quite complicated to automate
but the thumb bean talk of trying to use
RGB values instead of explicit labels
maybe one last question regarding the
color what do you do if the images are
not correct color corrected or do you
color correct them before you process
them because that would kind of I so I
don't actually know about the image
pre-processing pipeline I mean we're
lucky because the image is extremely
high quality we have maybe like three
thousand by three thousand pixels by
professional photographers and great
lighting and that sort of stuff because
it's basically the fashions brands
branding their quality of their images
so we do have really nicely calibrated
images placed true that could be
inconsistencies between retailers which
is messing stuff up haven't looked about
but might have a look fortunately we've
run out of time so thanks